the big interest for me is only think
the advertising is undergoing a bit of a
change at the moment and this might be
wishful thinking but there was such
euphoria a few years ago about how the
rise of data and the opportunities of
targeting was going to change
advertising that I think there was so
much over claim I think brands are very
excited and then a lot of those benefits
didn't materialize what I think we're
now seeing is an egg is that pendulum
swinging back from a fascination with
technology and it's not going to
disappear completely of course not but
swinging more towards some of those
eternal truths of that psychology
identifies so I think that's that to me
is a an exciting area at the moment that
more and more advertisers are thinking
well how can we on earth insights into
our audience by harnessing this field of
psychology behavioral science
I am joined by Richard chaton founder of
Astra tan and author of the choice
factory Richards welcome to the show all
right good to me Kris fantastic to have
you on just before we started you told
me that Astro 10 your company is
actually the wrong name for itself can
you can you explain what's happened
there
so I set it up last August and I was on
a holiday and it was getting to the
stage where I just needed a name and I
thought you know Richard shot in
consulting would just be a bit naff so I
was flicking through a textbook and
psychology experiments and I came across
this experiment back in the 60s which
was all about the the pernicious effects
of authority and in the in the
experiment what the psychologist did was
ring up hospitals to nurses quick quick
you've got to go and find patient Jones
and give them a hundred milligrams of
Astro ten and they shouldn't have
accepted the order over the phone and
when they got to the medicine cabinet
there was the fake medicine Astro ten
and it said in big letters don't give
anyone more than 10 milligrams yet
despite these two facts 95% of the
nurses try to administer the fake drug
did someone step in and go there was
someone you know hiding at that part but
the so I thought this is brilliant
relevant name for the company part of an
exciting experiment and also kind of
like the auntie thought
anti-authoritarian vibe you know it's
one of the reason for setting them up on
my own so I registered the name got the
website register that company's house
did all that stuff and they hit about a
month or two later I thought well if I'm
going to call myself Astro teller I
should probably read the original paper
and I went and found this paper and I
was lost halfway through I suddenly
realized about horror the the textbook
had had a typo so the the drug in the
real experiment back in the 60s was not
Astro ten it was a stroke GN so my
company it is a mistake your company's a
typo
companies at iphone but i thought after
that time one i couldn't be bothered to
real get another website and yeah i kind
of I kind of like the fact that you've
got a time yeah which is like again it's
human behavior right well yes well I
mean my favorite one of my favorite
biases is this idea of her drunk with a
pratfall effect so the pratfall effect
experiment back in done by early Eliot
arenson who's this professor at Harvard
he in the 1960s and in 1966 he runs his
classic experiment where he gets a
colleague of his to take part in a quiz
he has given his colleague all the
answers so the guy does amazingly well
gets 90 tubes and the questions right
wins the quiz by Miles looks like a
genius but then as the quiz is finishing
the guy makes one american call a
pratfall of small blunder as he's
standing up he spills a cup of coffee
down himself so Aaron turns recorded
this entire incident great quiz
performance and then the blunder he
plays it to people but he edits the the
clip so there are two versions one has
everything and the other version edits
out the mistake and when he asks
listeners how appealing they find the
contestant the contestant is seen is
significantly more appealing if people
have heard the mistake as well as the
amazing performance and Aronson calls
this the pratfall effect they saw idea
that we prefer people or relevantly for
advertisers products who exhibit a flaw
Anna and I love it because I think one
it runs very counter to what people
assume and then secondly if you look at
the greatest attic ads through history
it's interesting quite how many of them
have had this insight at their very
heart
what like so you go all the way back to
pre the earliest was 1959 VW had a
classic campaign adage that at age said
was the greatest campaign the 20 century
where they had flaws the very heart ugly
is only skin-deep
you've got more moving more recent walk
a little bit more recently with Avis
we're number two so we try harder
essentially Guinness admitting their
slow good things come to those who wait
Stella Raye ashore an expensive and more
recently Kate you know KFC tweeting them
their fries damn awful our fries told us
this so give us give us six months we'll
come back with a better recipe yeah yeah
say it say I think what those
advertisers have realized is that
probably the biggest hurdle you have as
advertiser well probably the biggest
hurdle has been noticed and actually the
pratfall affects good for that because
if everyone else is bragging if you are
distinctive you're much more likely to
be noticed and there's lots of evidence
about that it's a wonderful experiment
called the von restorff effect which
which proves that so it gets you noticed
the next biggest hurdle as an advertiser
is their believability you know most
people assume advertisers well you know
the cynics assume a lie which is not
true but most people assume that
advertise are at least putting a
positive spin on the truth it's an
amazing thing with the pratfall effects
is if you lit floor you've tangibly
demonstrated your honesty and then all
your other claims become that much more
believable and then I think the final
thing it does which is excellent is
those brilliant advertisers don't admit
a floor randomly they they go to great
lengths to think well what's our core
strengths and then they think about a
floor the it's the mirror image of that
strength because in many cultures flaws
and strengths are two sides the work the
same coin you know so Stella say they're
expensive but that's because they know
people assume that expensive things are
better quality or VW go out and say yes
we're ugly but then they follow up by
saying well that's because we don't care
about aesthetic fripperies we care about
engineering excellence
so it's this fascinating approach yet I
find it so interesting because even
though it's got all this evidence and
there's so
more than just the Aronson experiment
advertisers very very rarely use it you
know if you pick up if you watch a few
hours of TV tonight you'll see you
pre-owned see a single advertiser
admitting a weakness it's all very well
and good saying the best ones you use it
but they are in the they are in the
minority is it a way to humanize brands
other things that it does as you say if
you admit a weakness then you I think I
changing that kind of power dynamic yeah
definitely I mean looking at some of the
biggest memes and things that come out
of TV apart from the fact that it's
funny moment but if you look at the
stuff that comes off love island or it's
like dancing on ice celebrity dancing on
ice and stuff like that it's always
someone pulling an awkward face or
tripping up a step or something like
that like no one ever loves the person
who's flawless because I don't think
that they're able to relate and I think
that that's the same with the businesses
as well and obviously you don't want
Boeing Wow this is probably quite timely
like given how many issues they've had
recently with that three five seven max
or whatever it's called yeah you don't
want Boeing to be admitting like our
planes aren't that safe but they'll get
you there fast like don't talk about
that weakness mr. Boeing like let's not
bring that one up talk about the fact
that that harley-davidson one that you
posted on your Twitter the other day
amazing so there's a harley-davidson
advert guy and a bike on big open road
and it says at the bottom somewhere
through the 5,000 feet in the air a man
is trying to open a small packet of
peanuts [ __ ] genius that absolute
genius but yeah you're totally right
humanizing the brands and and being
strategic about it yes yes I think you
are they spot-on with that and two
things it's a humanizing the brand and a
Aaronson or it may be one of the
following experiment talks about if
someone seems perfect then people want
see them as a threat and want to knock
them down a peg or two
if someone's floored then you know
they're not they're not a threat
you can be much more likely to warmth
them but the other party been shy think
you're spot-on of you don't just pick a
floor randomly you know Stella didn't
say it tasted awful as you say you know
she does and say you didn't say that
we're lying about our emissions which
they were there all of those things like
Guiness I'm sure we're told in research
group after research group how annoying
it was that people had to wait for them
but rather than just brush that under
the carpet as most brands are do ya
thought well people know this it's true
might as well try and get some out mile
each other yeah how can we play off the
back of it and definitely using some of
those things as an indicator of quality
that's what's happening isn't it it's
price as an indicator of quality the
wait time is an indicator of quality
it's what is a characteristic people
want and how can we make our weakness be
some sort of a signal that that is an
important part of it I was talking about
Guinness I was recently in America and I
was at the United States national
whitewater rafting Center which is yep
anyone who's ever worn Patagonia like
that's where they will that's that's
their heavy yeah that's where they died
and go to it's like mountain biking and
hill climbing and whitewater rafting all
this stuff and at this the they don't
have a bar that serves alcohol but they
have a bar which has numerous cold brew
coffee zhan tap I was like and sure
enough they have one which takes the
same time as Guinness to pour and that's
its advertising strategy oh yeah pint of
just under a pint of cold brew coffee
but it settles the same way it gets
poured the same way they have to till
the kelp the cup in the same way they
get with the logo turn algae oh [ __ ]
across I was like see this is cool that
is fascinating
I'm not quite linked the two but there
is another bias called the IKEA effect
by Dan Ariely and Norton what they talk
about is generally removing friction
making things easier is a massively
underrate
did approach for marketers and people
who want behavior change so that however
they they argue they're a rare occasions
when you should try and make things
harder and at the beginning of the paper
they talked about a famous story from
General Mills and Betty Crocker so if
you've heard about this one it's back in
the 1950s
you've got more households were both men
and women are working so there's less
time to cook cakes for the kids so that
the General Mills think well you know
how do we tap into this changing
behavior well let's make super simple
cake mix a cake mix all you have to do
tear the top of the packet open pour it
in a tin add some water Chuck in the
oven and if lovely cake half an hour
later they launch this and despite it
seeming being absolutely spot-on for the
era cakes out there are awful they then
ponder why this is for a while and they
begin to think well we've made this too
easy because a cake isn't just about
providing calories for your family it's
about showing your love and if you've
made something really really easy it
doesn't show that because part of that
is going through a bit of rigmarole so
they then follow up with a new cake mix
in which they artificially make the cake
mix more complicated they make it harder
to bake so now you have got still where
your cake mix in your packet still tear
it open you still pour it in the tin
this time you have to crack an egg into
it
and now by making it harder once they've
done that that's when the cake stir mix
out start to take off cost and ignoring
the cost is time there I mean the Norton
and really call it the Orakei effect
that the more effort we put into
something the more we appreciate it I
think there's an element that in in your
cold brew coffee story and I've heard
I've had a few of them actually someone
else taught me and said this one
interesting if any letters know if this
is um this is true or not but someone
say
to me and speak to separate web
designers so reason math trust it they
said you know when you go on those
travel comparison sites they said aren't
you suspicious about the amount of time
it takes for them to search the site so
they said look they could do that much
quicker but they just add this second or
two a friction in to make the search for
those hotels or airplanes feels like
it's been far more authoritative form or
comprehend this is how hard we've got to
scrape the data to get you a deal I'm
not going I'm gonna make sure that I
keep this sufficiently anonymous that it
won't rumble him I know a person who
knows a person and this person is
currently working in a city doing some
financial stuff he has a part of this
thing he provides spreadsheet very
advanced spreadsheets with vlookups and
all sorts of other things to do
projections and forecasts that take into
account a lot of very complicated
variables and what he's added into this
spreadsheet is a macro that runs a
loading bar now you'll never know
because I've managed to keep him
sufficiently anonymous but if you are
the person that's being served this
excel sheet let me tell you that that
loading bar is always three and a half
seconds long no matter how much data
goes through it's just an animation it's
just an animation he thought if I had
this in it looks like I'm really [ __ ]
doing somewhere in the numbers behind
here meanwhile is computers like having
a tab it's his process is out the back
just having a cigarette going out if I
could finish three minutes ago 3-hour
seconds ago yeah that you totally right
I think um rory sutherland talks about
the difference between pick your own
strawberries and cheap strawberries okay
so you can imagine the same thing that
if price is an indicator of quality but
if price is offset with some cost you
have to incur in the creation of the
product you can sell strawberries for
half the price of everybody else's
strawberries if no one is suspicious
about the fat hang on what's good eat
strawberries so cheap so you're gonna go
pick them yourself
the sensors at IKEA why is why is IKEA
furniture so cheap oh I don't need to
worry about the quality it's because I
got
together myself that's why I have yes I
think you're absolutely right there and
if there is one category of brands that
should always be thinking about using
the pratfall effect I think it is low
cost brands because if they do nothing
people will assume their yeah their
product is [ __ ] seen it again again
working with brands that maybe had a
revolutionary way of bringing their
products ìmake they're done saying
really clever which means they're much
cheaper and then they'll get their
tracking back and that and off they
often come back with very low quality
scores because people were to rule of
thumb as you say if it's cheap it must
be [ __ ] and I think it was I'm sure
where it was Rory who had this brilliant
explanation for that success of budget
airlines you know he's argument is look
what they had to do when they launched
because they were such a strange thing
you know one day you were flying across
Europe for a hundred quid and now it
only costs a fiver they had to go out
and say their service was awful if they
hadn't people would assumed the cost
savings might have been at something
like safety yeah yeah so they'd have
never set foot in them go and say well
actually our service is awful and you
know I think that's a Michael O'Leary
about how much you can have push that
that message if you do that people think
well that's a fair enough trade-off and
they're happy to set foot on the planes
yes I think you're right if you ever
have a low-cost product you've got to be
thinking about well how can we explain
this price to people and if we can't try
and explain it with a bit of a humble
brag people assume that's too good to be
true needs go and find an
inconsequential weakness yeah you know
like TK Maxx admit that their stores are
shambolic oh my god it's a oh yeah
better to admit that then people go away
thinking it's the quality of the product
that's awful yeah I mean TK Maxx anybody
have some friends who shop in TK Maxx
and it is to me it is what if an anxiety
attack manifested itself it's a store
that's what TK Maxx would be Jamie like
there's no logic to it
you've got the scented candles next to
the flip-flops yeah
are you like who
on earth desert it's like a drunk child
designer this show unbelievable well
that thing there I don't know if they're
still running but certainly they had a
wave of advertising about six months ago
which said something along lines of the
small prices you pay for the small
prices you pay it might be Senate
chemical next a flip-flop but if you put
that bet of effort in your landowner the
bargain so when when someone works in an
ad agency right and they're coming up
with the marketing communications for
this that small prices you pay for the
small prices you pay for instance as a
tagline has probably has probably come
by one person perhaps it's not multiple
people that have come up with small
prices you play it'll just be some guy
because I've done advertising for a long
time for my own stuff the idea of being
the guy that comes up with that no
matter whether it makes any difference
to my paycheck gives me such a
figurative stiffy like to think I could
be the guy that did the small prices you
pay for the small prices you pay you
like yes that's my month made like
because you just come up with this
awesome awesome tagline do you get that
sense sometimes when you kind of you
finally hit upon the right brand message
the right trigger the right caption the
right everything and it just comes
together like that so so more speciality
slightly different more in ease around
well how you apply behavioral science to
marking this there's definitely a link
but no I'm sure I'm sure that's yeah
that's absolutely so yeah if I tried to
write that line it'd have been about a
paragraph mistakes in yeah
so what else have you seen recently is
anything else caught your eye recently
that you've been looking at in terms of
advertising I think I mean the interest
the big interest for me is I think the
advertising is undergoing a bit of a
change at the moment and this might be
wishful thinking but there was such
euphoria a few years ago about how the
rise of data and the opportunities of
targeting was going to change
advertising that I think there was so
much over claim I think brands got very
excited and
a lot of those benefits didn't
materialize what I think we're now
seeing is an egg is the pendulum
swinging back from a fascination with
technology and it's not gonna disappear
completely of course not but swinging
more towards some of those eternal
truths of that psychology identifies so
I think that's that to me is a an
exciting area at the moment that more
and more advertisers are thinking well
how can we unearth insights into our
audience I para nursing this field of
psychology of behavioral science yeah
Rory said on the podcast that ended with
him Silicon Valley sees everything as an
optimization problem so because what I
think Rory's brilliant often at talking
about is sometimes when you talk about
Silicon Valley or big tech if the their
success is often attributed solely to
their technological brilliance but often
and I don't know if he covered akale did
a great podcast with my comment whether
you covered this or not but often their
success has some quite clever
psychological insights of their heart as
well so uber for example of course you
know that functionality behind that you
know it is amazing but there are some
really clever psychological points there
as well that there is research like I
remember the name of the psychologist
but this quite a lot of research that
shows that specific weights as in I know
I've got to wait five minutes is much
less painful than an unspecified way
that ends up being five minutes okay
it's one of the great things that Disney
do they when you get to that twenty
minutes from the hit point yes exactly
so people can quit worrying about where
they're getting it to the front or not
they could do something else for twenty
minutes and have a chat and then so it
removes the pain said that they were
brilliant on that but the other bit that
I think they're amazing at and I think
this is key to their success is the
means of payment now there is lots of
ever
it's that the the Morse distance you put
between someone getting your products
and then handing over cash the cheaper
it feels so you know when you go to a
casino they don't expect you to be
putting down ten pound notes the table
they get you to turn that cash into
chips mmm people come less price
sensitive when people have credit cards
have become less price sensitive than
cash I mean I thought you went when you
were abroad as well and you're using
plastic this is everyone makes the same
joke but you're not quite sure the
conversion rate yeah yeah I think I've
never seen any studies in that by I bet
you I bet you're right the one I've done
which was it might have been the first
ever experiment I ran with a lovely
research called Claire Linford and it
was about contactless payment so we wait
until people came out from coffee shops
mini-marts little delis and then we
stopped and said can you answer three
questions and we said how much have you
paid can we see your receipt and how
much for you paid what was remains of
payment and then can we see your receipt
and so we compared what they thought
they'd paid with their receipt was what
actually paid and then we've got the
data by means of payment so people pay
with cash three quarters ish I think and
you exactly what they're paid hmm those
who don't overestimated their spend by
about I think is about 10% credit cards
two-thirds and you exactly what they'd
spend and when they did and there was
like to underestimate is overestimate
contactless less than half remember they
verbally underestimate this Bend so you
had this swing of about 15 percent in
memory of spend between cash
overestimating contactless under
estimating so that to me you know an
uber I would say is more extreme than
even contactless people treat it as free
because there is is so little friction
there's so little pain of payment the
people treat it like is you say monopoly
is black monopoly
buy it now on Amazon yeah yeah but yeah
okay one one click one click go drink
sorry it's the fact that you can swipe
to the right all you need to do is press
a button on Amazon swipe to the right
and then to goose down pillows arrive in
your house the next day three thousand
[ __ ] is even studies I mean goes as far
as I think yes it's Sybil yang Sybil
yang did a study on restaurant menus
where she showed if you take off they
would be back she's American so being
dollar signs if you take off the dollar
signs people come a percent less price
sensitive you know it can be tiny tiny
tweaks that will affect that degree of
price sensitivity and price sensitivity
is hugely important to brands now
because if you're operating on hopefully
I'm getting my math right yeah but if
you're operating a 20% margin gain an
extra 1% on the price is worth no marks
an extra in terms of sales yeah well I
mean if you are a restaurant owner
actually if you're going out for dinner
tonight have a look at the menu see if
there is or is not a pound sign on that
and that will tell you how well versed
the restaurant owner is in behavioral
economics and behavioral signs and then
give us a tweet and tell us because I
want to find out all there may be in
that because it's fascinating in the
looking far from some of these brands
there is often a question well were they
applying behavioral science well I think
in the menu case a lot of it is maybe
some people originally did it because
they'd read about this civil yang
experimentation but it looks cleaner as
well and I wonder if other people just
copied it oh that looks quite pretty a
little bit smarter say it's hard to know
one has someone applied it because of
their knowledge of bio science so it
might be they've never studied the
subject matter but they are keen student
of human nature hmm like going back it's
the pratfall effect Eliot arenson did
that study in 1966 in 1959 it was seven
years earlier that bill Bernbach you
know one of the great advertising
creatives that's when he had run that VW
campaign that were admitted the floors
he came out with a phrase a smaller
mission gains a large acceptance you
know before the academics had actually
done the studying so sometimes I think
people are getting these ideas you know
they're working day in day out with
customers and then they're watching how
people behave then I think they pick
them up through you know osmosis rather
than academic study yeah you are right
there's this trickle-down effect of that
we find that in the industry I work in
which is nightlife promotion ah
you only have a good idea for about a
month because after a month if it's that
good of an idea it's just been
emancipated by everybody else that was
good until everyone else found out and
because the unique thing about the
nightlife industry is know no one's
protecting their intellectual property
no one's got contracts in place it's the
most ice actually believe it's the most
Wild West industry probably outside of
the drug trade that's that's still
allowed to exist because no one
everything is up for grabs all the time
from night names to tag lines to
intellectual property to staff to event
to everything everything's up for grabs
and it's a ruthlessly interesting sort
of experiment to see what happens when
people try and hold on to ideas that
they've come up with yes for nightlife
that I didn't know that was your your
area
maybe the bias that's most regularly
applied by night clubs is the famous
attempts at building social proof now
build up so social proof this idea of we
don't make our decisions fully
individually we look around to what
others doing and things that are popular
become more popular still so the classic
night club trick of that was always you
know don't let people in straight away
build up the queue outside so it feels
like it's appealing you're giving away
all of us I think
fascinating idea because it's one of the
most proven biases in social psychology
children is shown it with towel reuse
Christakis with smoking HMRC with tax
repayment rates Fang with restaurant
menus again and again the if you tell
people what the popular course of
behavior is it becomes more popular
still but why I think it's really
interesting is the a lot of advertisers
are very literal in their interpretation
of that inside now so you go out and you
see beer brands saying they're Britain's
most popular or you know tonics
chocolate bar selling 5 million a week
or a call that 97 percent of CEOs use
them and I think that's all very well
and good but what marketers should
aspire to is not seeing the behavioral
science experiments as the endpoint I
think what they should aspire to is
thinking of them just as stimulus for
good ideas and then if they apply their
strengths of creative thinking that's
when the best ideas happen so seeing
that you've got your white earbuds on
that's probably my the Y ear but to
bring my favorite example of a brand
taking social proof and using it
laterally mmm think back to when iPod
launched what for 2001 ish when they
launched they were not the market leader
you know lots of other brands had got
out there first there's no way they
could honestly go out and say you know
we're the most popular brand buyers but
the other brands made a error of not
being very visible so if you were so
when people at Sony mp3 players no one
knew you know if you saw some on the
tube on the train all you would see is
their indistinct all black earphones
yeah that mp3 player itself was in the
person's pocket had no idea if it was
Sony or Motorola or Apple did so
brilliantly was making a massive play of
all their advertising folks on
the bright y earphones or the child
advertising folks on that very very
distinctive only person who did it so
soon as use the Y earphone you knew
someone was listening to Apple they
looked like they were the market leader
long before they were and that sitting
this virtuous circle setting training
this virtuous circle of social proof
yeah
so those natural harnessing the lateral
harnessing of these biases I thinks
becomes a really exciting when it's
through the design or through the
insinuation yeah so you're stranded on
an island yeah and you're allowed to
take five biases with you
are you allowed to be aware of five
biases so I'm gonna ask you to choose
your five favorite children okay we've
had the pratfall effect is that one of
your top five yeah I'd be like I love it
okay so yeah who's gonna be who's gonna
be number two and Y and let's go through
it okay so the second one I probably
have seen like price relativity so this
is the idea that consumers don't have a
fixed conception of Valley good what's
good Valley you know I think it really
sevens words there's no one walking
around the shops thinking they're
prepared to pay one pound per unit of
happiness whenever it's a or pair of
trainers just be too complex yeah so
what Daniel Kahneman talks about often
he says look when people have a complex
problem like is this thing good Valley
rather than try and weigh that up in a
very complex way they they replace the
complex calculation with a much simpler
calculation a calculation it's almost as
good but much simpler and the simpler
calculation is what did I pay for
something similar in the past if I'm now
being asked to pay more this new thing
is bad value if I'm now being asked to
pay less this new thing is a great value
now that should interest Marcus because
it means the people's conception of
value is not an absolute thing it's a
relative thing it depends what your
comparison says so if you can change the
comparison set for your product then
you can change people's willingness to
pay by orders of magnitude a reason
probably not the biggest one but a
reason one would be have you seen these
like seed lit non-alcoholic gin no it's
not an offer it's 25 quid okay and
everything they do about it is you know
the brand the imagery the bottle it
comes in the fact they call it a
non-alcoholic spirit it's it compares it
to other alcoholic drinks so when you
compare it with a gin you know 25 quid
is expensive but it's in line with an
auto scent gin and it sells a reasonably
well but if you think about what that
product is it's essentially an adult
cordial if you stuck next to revive inna
if that sold not on the G knob in the
Ribena oil and there's no way on earth
any right minded consumer would pay more
than a fiver but because people would
suddenly be saying well okay it's a bit
fancy than Ribena but that you know the
two pounds would be their comparison
they might pay double they're not gonna
pay tens as much by changing the
comparison sector gins they change
consumers willingness to pay by orders
of magnitude you know the more for the
famous example Britain
you know the example that's made
billions of pounds oh well on the Royce
element often talks about is in espresso
now he's argument there is what they
have brilliantly done by selling in pods
he's changed the comparison set because
a pod gives you a cup size serving and
as soon as people think of cups of
coffee
the comparison set and espresso is
Starbucks and a flat wine so the 50
pence that Nespresso want for a lungo
pot of coffee looks great value compared
to 2 / 5 for a Starbucks flat white if
and I reckon 99.9% of marketers would
have done this if they had launched in
bags of coffee if they'd sold in an
espresso powder in like a big bag of
coffee like Douw Egberts or cafe direct
how much do you reckon for standard 474
gram bag of coffee would have cost well
it's gonna be able to get a little bit
over the top of
it is already right you're not gonna be
talking to Starbucks prices well hey if
you if they sold 404 Graham back so I
think that would cost 60 pounds now
there is no way on earth again any would
go into Sainsbury's push aside a 10
pound bag of Dow Egberts away and take
home a 60 pound bag of Nespresso said
feel like so wasteful it feel morally
wrong now if but that's not what they
did you know the 50 pence for a pod
feels like a great value compared to
Starbucks the 60 pound for a bag which
is exactly the same per gram price that
would have felt a ripoff could have been
compared to a different collection of
items so that to me is one of the most
fascinating biases because it you can
change people's willingness to paper I
mean those exams to pre what you've
changed bills willing to pay by orders
of make sure about 10 Wow
no that's phenomenally so this is where
this is where I had never heard it
before but the first ever podcast that I
heard Rory Saldana Rory you may be
listening so I'm gonna send this to you
I apologize for your ears just like
burning some so hard that they're coming
off but if you are listening and you
haven't heard episode 49 with Rory
Sutherland it was at the start of the
year and it was a force of nature you
got to go watch it'll be in the show
notes below I remember that he was
discussing about so many of these
different elements and I think that the
fact there was nothing analogous in the
two situations you've got there's
nothing that someone can use what's
analogous to alcohol-free gin well when
it's in denial nothing and what's
analogous to Nespresso pod
well I can't work it out but no one
probably actually knows how many grams
are in a tea coffee that's instant
coffee did it like yeah you'd go insane
if you I mean people often use the word
irrationality about some of these biases
but it's a strange word to use because
it would be insane to go into the
supermarket and try and make all these
calculations wire up all these things
and not just compare it to what's in
front of you you know you'd spend your
whole spend a whole day in a supermarket
if you if you try to make all these
calculate an existential crisis
yes which I which I often have in ASDA
and but yet the the Rory Sutherland
point is the fact he talks I say is if
alchemy right
and I think oh yes yeah really relation
that he pulls out the first ever time
that I heard this used and revering I've
done I did master's in international
marketing at Newcastle University had
been at uni for five years I've done
advertising my entire life I'd never
thought of it like this but what he says
is that advertising is a kind of alchemy
because it allows you to create value
creation literally out of nothing
so the nespresso change in price by the
way that they have pitched themselves
and the style in which they've put the
product across there's no carbon
footprint there's no increased labor
there's no there's no cost of any kind
outside of its ability to simply be a
unique kind of offering so you're able
to create value from nothing and that's
where it gets the alchemy idea from I
think a brilliant book I think there's
also a value in the what people taste is
not necessarily just the product itself
so you talk about Nespresso or beer or
food people taste what they expect to
taste so there's a whole series of
experiments done by slightly
controversial professor called Brian
Wansink
where a different story before or
different label to a product to a food
creates a very different taste so if you
tell someone a wine is 50 quid and I
think this was done our ale actually
rather than one think to tell them at
wines fifty quid they'll like it much
more than the exactly the same one if
they're told it's a fiver one think did
stuff around labeling so you tell people
are why exactly going exactly they even
serve the same wine if they're told it's
from Dakota North Dakota they'll tell
you it's all full of a telex from
California it's lovely if they describe
a soup with loads of fancy adjectives
then it's rated higher and people will
pay more and I think it tastes better
than if it's just described in very
plain terms so you know yes people you
know add adding that thought and effort
to the design the advertising the
labeling the packaging it creates value
in people's heads and why is that any
less value
than the enjoyments of created by
playing around with the the chemical and
the physical a physical makeup yeah
I agreed so we've got the pratfall
effect we've got what was the second
cost relativity price relativity yeah
well so we're on the we're on the island
they will know that we know over and we
know that spilled coffee on ourselves
yeah we know to make things on analogous
to other products so that the customers
don't know what's going on what else is
up yeah for different reasons I would
probably have nine Enders damn we
should've done this podcast we should
have done it in eight years time it's a
nine Enders is the idea that from Adam
alter and how Hirschfeld the people
whose age ends in nine are particularly
likely to make big major lifestyle
decisions so well I figured my wrench
when I first read this was this sounds
it's hokum and at first I wasn't
persuaded by their initial what he
initiatives mess is well we proved this
by running a huge global survey I think
it's 40 or thousand people and people
were much more likely to agree with a
statement
I've made a big lifestyle change in the
last 12 months if their age ends in a
nine okay but there's all sorts of
problems with claim data so that that's
a little bit weak but what they then did
was brilliant they looked at loads of
observed data sets to try and test their
hypothesis so they look at first time
marathon runners and their 48 percent
more likely to Durham a from the first
time when their age ends in nine they'd
look at again they look at fairs
websites they look at Ashley Madison I
mean this this is not great Affairs
website they gave their eight million
database of men to these researchers and
they found that men were 18% more likely
to join this website when their age ends
in nine they even looked and this gets a
bit more depressing they looked at
American suicide data and there is a
small but statistically significant
uplift
in suicides when people's agents in nine
now what are they then obvious that so
robust study because they're
prioritizing observe they are over claim
data they argue that this happens
because people perp
they don't treat all time is equal some
moments are given disproportionate
importance so when people approaching
the turn of a decade that has big
cultural significance so in that twelve
months before people are at least
thinking well how is my life going and a
lot
most people think was actually fine
don't make any changes but there's a
large enough proportion who think things
are going poorly they make these big
radical changes then part of the reason
I take this the desert island is I like
this because it's practical you know ten
years ago knowing that as an advertiser
well what the hell'd you do with it now
it is very very simple there loads of
digital media owners capsules birthday
is very very easiest target people buy
but the other reason this separate why
makes on the top five I love it is
there's a really strong economic reason
for using this bias like if you are a if
you're the government try to get people
to stop smoking if you're a diet brand
if you're a gym brand if you're press
seller of luxury convertibles you know
targeting people whose Asians in nine
when they are a bit mulling over the
direction the life it's very very very
personal time but the reason I love it
from the economics of it is media when
advertisers buy media space it's
increasingly bought through an auction
so in the mid seconds voice in AD and
auctions gone on and the winner gets to
serve their ad there if you are in an or
if you are using the same data signals
as every other brand and most brands
will default to income you know 1834 was
ABC ones if you're just buying on the
same metric as everyone else well when
you're in a busy auction you tend to
overpay what you need to do is isolate a
fact that no one else is using like are
NDErs bid on that and you're much more
likely to get a bargain
so I think no lenders makes it because
at first I was very doubtful I loved the
creativity the altar and Hirschfeld show
to test this point and then I love the
fact that it's both practical and
there's some economics behind it I can't
get over the name we've come up with
this thing what do you think what do you
just don't hear me out hear me out just
wait what do we think of as a name as 9
Enders you'd be like right love the
energy great just change the title out
and we're sweet was sweet and yeah I
mean very first chair I've got no right
to talk sweating what about naming it
wasn't called like Astro tenders though
was it okay so we've got those we've got
nine Enders we've got a price it costs
relativity we've got the pratfall effect
what else what else is in on this on the
island the island well I would have and
this is it's related so the danger of
claim dater I think you know and
touching on that with nine Enders there
is a lovely experiment by Adrian North
who's at the University of Leicester and
and his experiment was around playing
different music in the wine aisle of a
supermarket so some occasions he plays
and it's stereotypically French music
accordion stuff and some to play
stereotypically German music brass bands
and things and then he monitors the
proportion of wine sows ignores all the
other nations just looks at French and
German wine sales hmm when the French
music plays seventy-seven percent of the
wine from those two countries is French
27 percent German when the German music
plays 73 percent is German 27 percent
20-some percent French so the the
nationality being bought Suede's
massively to this small in
or queue so part of it he's experiencing
mainly about the music and the
importance of these environmental cues
but what's interesting from another
perspective is what he does next
as people are leaving the supermarket
he stops them and he says did you buy
any wine did you buy any French or
German wine and then if they've said yes
to both those questions he says well why
did you buy that wine and only 2% of
people say they bought the wine because
of the music and even when he asked them
directly even when he says look did the
music influence you 86% of people deny
flat out the music had any effect at all
I think if you're a marketer if you take
actual if you change one thing from this
podcast it should be based on that
experiment which is be very very careful
about taking customers claims at face
value you know because if you run that
test and then are you know or you would
think about that running that test and
did what most marketers do which is
survey people and then you know listen
to the survey results if you went and
said would the music changing the music
influence you everyone says no you don't
bother doing it so if you're a mark to
be very skeptical about survey results
focus groups directly asking people and
certainly be skips about taking those
claims at face value and instead I would
say the thing to learn from psychology
is this methodology of not listening to
claims but setting up these tests and
control experiments it's a naturalistic
experiment you know in the wine aisle
for example if your wine brand keep
everything the same except for one
variable the music and then difference
in sales or whatever behave you want you
would tribute back to that change
variable that's a far better way to
unearthing genuine motivations Daniel
Kahneman talks about this a lot that we
don't we don't know our own biases right
we haven't got a clue about our own
motivations for doing particular things
you mentioned about alcohol
in supermarkets I haven't seen this in
the UK but was recently in America and
in America they have bars from like a
pub not that far behind the fruit and
veg aisle so you hit fruit and veg then
you hit a bar and yeah you hit like
bread then the number of dad's that had
seen that were there who'd obviously
said to their partners right don't worry
don't worry darling I'll take the fish
I'll take the kids for this one and then
one of the one of the trolleys oh my god
this is trolley right and it's double
child seat thing at the front cup holder
at the back dad just going around with
an IPA brew dog or like a blue moon or
something like that and he's just
sipping away obviously throwing loads of
stuff in he doesn't need like it's just
loosened these spending muscles a little
bit like like loads of fajita mix and
things he's never gonna use yeah yeah
great removing the pound signs the
dollar signs were a menu two points of
IPA about get the price and I can't I
think it was a Paco Underhill I think
that might be his name apology I've got
I've got that wrong but he wrote a book
and I think it's there that I first read
and it might be worth double-checking
this one to make sure it's true but the
reason why supermarkets half because you
mentioned even in that example that the
fruit and veggie comes first
she's completely impractical if you
think about it if you go if the first
thing you see is delicate soft squidgy
fruit and vege the blast patient that is
the bottom of your trolley when all the
heavy stuff is getting in front but
there is an idea in psychology called
moral licensing which is if we do
something good you know ethically right
virtuous I like going to the gym having
some vitamins we often overcompensate so
you get people feeling like they've been
very healthy with a fruit veg that might
be the reason for having that right at
the beginning so then compensate with
biscuits and treats and whatever else
so an awful lot of psychology that goes
into the design of supermarkets right
with shelf height and the different ways
that prices are displayed I seem to
remember one of the very few things that
I can remember from my degree which I
paid 27 grand for a map about how
customers typically walk down aisles and
it's similar to if you were to take a
ping-pong ball or a bowling ball put the
guardrails up and throw it yeah you you
would see just this angle that almost
the angle of attack is the angle of exit
dink dink dink and they just go the way
all the way up I remember seeing that
now it was first off I it was at
Newcastle University's marketing
department and I'm unsure how many
accolades they've got so it might have
been wrong but that I'm fascinated with
the design of supermarkets and I only
try and find myself like catching like
what is what are they doing this week
well I bought I bought recently
purchased a 867 gram bag of crave cereal
just because I was like that's the
largest bag of crave cereal is just
multiples of smaller bags of crave
cereal that I've had before there's
nothing I don't even think it was that
cheap well just like oh look at that I
mean I have heard people arguing that
one of the reasons it it's easier to
change the size of your products then
put the price up so if you reduce the
size of your crisps all your sweets
people are less likely to stop buying
you than if you put up the price but
same or if it's a massive bag well then
again what you compare it to you know I
know you know for me Krista's my
weakness underground bag you know I'll
recommend that should be about a pound
pound 50 if it's 150 75 you know
suddenly my benchmarks out out the
window oh yeah well I guess when redbull
first launched right there this weird
tongue oddly sized guys it too
1:58 it's thin silicon it's breaking
that link with you've got the 330 which
is the coca-cola stub yeah and then
you'd have like a monster equivalent
which is like a pint or something that's
like it no like a four six seven or
something like that but I think monster
came much later it yeah so once that
link with comparing with soft drinks is
broken then you can gradually drift into
it
so at craft beer when craft beer
launched you never ever saw or I
certainly never saw a craft beer sending
in a 440 milk n because the link it'll
be too obvious that they want four
pounds so they so paradox see they make
it smaller to be able to self more now
very occasionally you do see for 40
local cans but that's cuz I think
they've set up craft beer has been a
different category different price
expectations them free allow yeah I do I
get that completely one of the
interesting things I wonder about you
were talking about how you can
manipulate your GP on a product by
lowering the price which means sorry
lowering the volume which means you've
got less product inside of that now a
number of bar and club owners from
around the country will know this
problem which is that something like
Carlsberg sorry Carlsberg but cars bergs
about the cheapest maine beer that you
can buy from from a brewery with a
reputable name and more than 50% of the
cost of the beer comes from the bottle
so if you were to reduce the size of the
bottle all that you would be concerned
with is using or you would be equally
concerned with using less glass yeah as
you would be for using less beer which
is hilarious also on a side point I have
managed a Carlsberg that I get I get
spat on for drinking Carlsberg right
like when I don't drink at the moment
but when I do drink I tend to drink
Carlsberg and this is this weird
artifact of years of working in student
club nights where if I wanted to get the
cheapest beer would always be Carlsberg
and if the club manager was going to
give us a couple of beers while we were
cashing up at the end
you always bring in obviously the stuff
that he doesn't really like it's 47
pence a unit or something plus VAT yeah
I do I care about giving giving you like
two quids worth of Carlsberg for you and
a couple of the lads there cash in the
till at the end of the night yeah but
oddly over time I've actually developed
like a weird like Pavlov's dog type
thing I'm like end of the night need a
Carlsberg and now that's even expanded
itself out to the point where it's like
I'm out on a night want a Carlsberg and
everyone else will be like getting a
corona or getting something like copper
burger so mannequin yeah really
Carlsberg at the back please I don't
know I've been promoting for like 13
years me alone well if anyone takes the
mick and people can be strangely snobby
about the coffee and beer at the moment
i today we did a taste test and i think
the main reason we did the taste test
try think we were testing effective that
the serving on the taste so headline
figure was for if you get in a plastic
last you think it's all full unbranded
it's bit better say this is the same
liquid brandy glass it rates nicer but
one of the things we did was we gave we
confound bloke between 18 and 30 gave
them fan out where they were Foster's
Carlsberg or Carling drinkers and some
people would be quite you know
passionate about one of them and talked
very dismissive about the other two and
then we gave them applying taste test of
the three beers and people were worse
than chance at picking out their
supposedly related beer so yes and maybe
put some cash on that next time one of
your Corona drinking friends mocks cars
so did we get did you get number four
did we go number four number four I
think four was claimed a yeah yes number
four the foreigner one yeah this is more
for it's my favorite story for how cycle
just came up with the idea and it's the
if you love the dunning-kruger effect
yeah okay so for the listeners it'll be
worth explaining it yeah yeah so David
Dunning
Justin yeah - I think so cause it's
Cornell they're reading a local paper
and they come across the story of
McArthur wheeler
so McArthur wheeler has just been jailed
for 20 years for committing to bank
robberies so in a single day he dropped
two banks a time he drove home the
police are waiting for him and they
arrest him and the reason that they
caught him so quickly was that unlike
most burglars
bank robbers he didn't bother covering
his face with the balaclava he turned up
at the bank and the only precaution he'd
taken was he smeared his face with lemon
trees because his mate had told him that
lemon juice is what you know you make
invisible in count of so therefore if
you put the juice on your face the
security cameras won't go out to pick
you up and supposedly he tried he's not
completely yeah he's a bit he try he
test this theory he takes her selfie of
himself but he manages to kind of shoot
the ball behind him he's angled right
and [ __ ] my lemon in his eyes that's
why read about this and they think wait
a minute there is a massive vest
interest in this person knowing their
abilities actually so how can they be so
deluded about their ability to rob a
bank and get away with it
and they began to wonder is this
although but that of course is a very
very extreme aversion is that typical of
other people so they begin by testing
people they give them grammar tests and
the logic test math tests get them to do
these tests note down where they have
appeared from you know in you know let's
say they get a hundred people to do it
what percentage they've you know they're
ranked US and then they get the people
to estimate where they've appeared now
in general people are overconfident they
think they're better than average and
how everyone can't be better than
average but the Keith ym knows the
dunning-kruger effect rather than just
the ball
competence was they noted that people
who were experts sometimes underestimate
their abilities when people were novices
and pretty darn awful they were more
more like but there was a bigger kind of
over estimate of their abilities so it's
kind of idea that when you're Eddie bad
at something you really do overestimate
how good you are so chemic known as it's
done in crew graphics now I think
there's loads of fascinating patience
for marketers about overconfidence that
too often great campaigns at jettison
too early because people believe well I
did a brilliant campaign you know ten
years ago that's running out of juice
now I'm gonna do up another great one
they overestimate their ability but I
think the main reason that makes the
desert island is the MacArthur Buddhist
weird a story for me I think is thing I
didn't know the lemon juice thing good
so we're gonna finish up shortly Richard
have you got any any bits that you've
seen recently if you got one more little
anecdote or one more little thing that
you've got joy down that you think would
be a good way to finish finish off the
episode today the I think I think the
best example I've seen recently and
maybe we'll have to stick an image up
here because my description I did
unfortunately and I do like trying
credit Felix it's not fair to not
mention but there was a wonderful tweet
recently where some had taken a photo of
a sign in a little corner shop and it
was centrally said Durex condoms
five dollars Trojan condoms five dollars
Huggies twenty two dollars I think
that's the price relativity I've ever
seen don't pay off that your ex compare
yourself to Huggies and subtle earlier
you look much cheaper there's a there's
a so recently on your Twitter the one
about beware pickpockets operate in this
area was a pork
even does this wonderful talk at
non-stock where he said look people
assume communications work rationally so
you put up a sign saying beware
pickpockets operate in this area shortly
we've now communicated the information
this is a dangerous area pickpocketing
rates drop what he says is that that
actually tends to backfire because when
people see that sign there automatic
responses without thinking to straight
away you know tap their pockets to make
all of their valuable areas of their
body thank you very much you've just
identified where your wallet is I'll be
having about yeah Wow well I recently
went to Barcelona and one of the guys
that I was with fell asleep in Barcelona
train station after a bit of a heavy
night now Barcelona is the pickpocket
capital of Europe apparently I didn't
know but he found that out when he woke
up to notice his phone wallet and shoes
had been taken she's taken from his feet
that's just a master pickpocket on that
actually another great advert or not
just saw this one was from Ogilvy they
ran a campaign warning people about
pickpockets where they used X
pickpockets who'd kind of seen the lie
and they had a campaign called put two
pockets so they got the pickpocket to
drop a little flyer in people's pockets
saying well I it was easy enough for me
to put this in your pocket I could have
helped myself everywhere to be much more
careful and I loved that as a way of
tell people they are in danger you know
can I show them and that's much much
more powerful you know going back to
that in Kruger where you know or deque
have generalized finding of
overconfidence if you say you know this
area is danger for pickpockets or or you
know you need to be more careful with
your valuables
most people think well it's not going to
happen to me all happen to those other
idiots it's one of those is a great it's
one of those things like the ethical
hackers you know they get the ethical
hackers to come on board and
hack into a company on behalf of the
company and it's alwa we've identified
the hole in your particular system this
is the way that we go in I want to know
what a ethical pickpocketer gets paged
get paid based on the number of Flyers
that he gives out because that really
should be and it's a toll what I gave I
gave this to a really rich guy and I
know for a fact that that Rolex is worth
5 grand so I really need any big money
for him any big money for that woman
with a levite on purse and I don't pay
for the ethical pickpockets they'll have
a gurney in soon the lover Union but
Richard today's been awesome man thank
you so much
where can everyone find you online I
absolutely love your Twitter what what
should they follow up so at our chaton
our sh o TT owen and the book i wrote
which is all about applying behavioral
science to advertising is called the
choice factory fantastic and then the
third thing I've done which might be of
interest is I've just created a online
training course yeah that's exactly
exactly
so Rory something's done one about
applying behavioral science or about
behavioral science in general I've done
one specifically on applying behavioral
science to advertising Wow so it links
to all of that will be in the show notes
below if you want to follow Richard on
on Twitter he's very active and it's
just like when I log on now I've been
following you maybe for a week just over
a week something like that when I log on
is just at the top of my feed I only
followed 68 people so it's like that
it's a good choice you know it's a real
mark of something for you to get in
there and I just go on and I'm like it's
always media based there was a recent
story about Julius Caesar about I'll
tell you what why don't we finish with
the stop about Julius Caesar can you
remember that yes yes so this is from a
brilliant book for it actually an
amazing advertiser kind of in his heyday
seventies 89 it's called Dave Trott and
he's written a lovely book called
creative blindness and he talks about
Julius Caesar so age 23 Julius Caesar is
captured by some
pirates and they want to ask for 20
units of silver and truly Caesar says no
no no hang on don't ask for 20 I'm worth
far more than that ask for 50 and this
is the finest man that any you know
politician general whatever has been
ransom for so all of a sudden people
like God this Caesar man must be amazing
you know if he's being asked for you
know the Pirates reckon he's worth that
much and in this blog that kind of photo
to snippet from from David Rock he
essentially argues that Caesar invented
the idea thousand years before the
Veblen effects and that's the idea we
touched on with Stella that people
assume something that is expensive must
be high quality
so Caesars working on the idea that well
you know if I go and say that I had you
know the highest ransom ever and people
are going to see him I must be an
amazing general and that's gonna set off
my political career despite the fact
that he came up with the prize yeah this
is someone when I love the thing about
Twitter is someone and actually came
came back and sent me a link to a longer
article about Caesar an invention that
when Caesar was released he then raised
you know a bad kind of armed party went
back and found the Pirates who were
still sitting around the same island
caught them and then had them all
executed so I mean you know you want to
be it was a man that they probably
shouldn't have messed with for a few
reasons not just his marketing now Shafi
with behavioral science but then then
he's gonna make himself really well
known and super popular Danny's gonna
come back he's gonna kill you you do not
mess with Julius Caesar
Richard today's been fantastic man
everybody who is listening please go and
follow Richard on on Twitter he's
absolutely fascinating any other points
that have come up that you've been
interested in feel free to give me a
message wherever you follow me at Chris
relax or Richard on to
and we'll be more than happy to start
the discussion yet again over the
interwebs Richard thanks so much for
your time man thanks a lot
[Music]
you